[MUSIC PLAYING]
STEVE GREENBERG:
Scikit-Learn and XGBoost
are machine-learning
frameworks as part
of the Python ecosystem.
And I'm a huge fan
of these frameworks.
I use them for my work.
And I genuinely find
them to be a joy to use.
If your experienced with
Scikit-Learn and XGBoost,
this talk is meant to give you
some practical tips for how
you can use the cloud to
get your job done better.
But if you're new
to the frameworks,
the next couple of slides will
give you a quick introduction.
So the first thing
to understand is
that Scikit-Learn
and XGBoost are
part of a larger Python
ecosystem for data science
which is incredibly rich.
From low-level libraries like
numpy and pandas all the way up
through graphing and
matplotlib and the frameworks
we're talking about today.
Python has a ton of frameworks
to make data science easy.
Python was the
most preferred tool
cited in Kaggle's most recent
ML and data science survey.
Scikit-Learn is an
open-source framework
on Python for doing a
wide variety of ML tasks.
The name Scikit-Learn
is derived from it
being a toolkit for
machine learning
that's part of the
scientific Python community.
And I have to say,
I'm personally
thrilled to be here
today with David.
In 2007, David
created Scikit-Learn
as part of a Google
Summer of Code project.
Scikit-Learn is, by the way,
often abbreviated SK-Learn.
And I think you'll hear us use
both terms interchangeably.
So unlike Scikit-Learn, which
supports dozens and dozens
of algorithms, XGBoost supports
one, but does a fantastic job
with it.
So basically, XGBoost stands
for Extreme Gradient Boosted
decision trees.
So gradient boosted
decision trees
are ensembles of decision trees
in which each subsequent tree
attempts to correct the mistakes
made by the prior trees.
And it's proven to be an
incredibly effective method
of doing ML.
I was talking with Ben Hamner,
who is the CTO of Kaggle.
And he told me that
XGBoost is behind almost
every recent winning submission
to a Kaggle competition,
except for computer
vision competitions.
And that brings me to
an important point.
So neither XGBoost
nor SK-Learn is
optimized around deep
learning or neural networks.
And that's a key
difference from TensorFlow.
Now, you're at a
Google conference,
and you're hearing a
lot about TensorFlow.
So I just want to
take a moment here.
TensorFlow is truly remarkable,
and you should definitely
go and learn a lot about it.
But for a class of
problems, and, I think,
for a class of problems
that happens to actually
be very common in
businesses, I think the ROI
from XGBoost and SK-Learn can
be higher than TensorFlow.
You'll get great results
without a ton of effort.
So we're going to focus
on three stages of ML
during today's presentation.
Preprocessing is the
stage in which you
make data ready for training.
Training is the stage
in which you take labels
data, train on it so that
you can predict a target
variable in the future
for unlabelled data.
And then prediction
is the stage in which
you take unlabelled data and
predict new values for it.
And how do these frameworks
play into these three phases?
Preprocessing often requires
transformations in NumPy
or pandas.
But Scikit-Learn also
provides its own libraries
for preprocessing.
You can do feature selection
and feature engineering
with Scikit-Learn itself.
And one of the best
things about Scikit-Learn
is the consistency
of its interface.
So you can take any algorithm
in Scikit-Learn and call .fit
on it and get a trained model.
And once you have
a trained model,
you can take any of them and
call .predict on it and get
predictions out.
This interface is
incredibly powerful.
And I think it's what makes
Scikit-Learn a ton of fun
to use.
XGBoost supports
that same interface,
which is really cool.
So if you built your
pipeline to use Scikit-Learn,
you can often switch XGBoost
into it pretty seamlessly.
And one of the things
you'll see today
is that we're going
to do some demos.
The demos all use Scikit-Learn
and Scikit-Learn pipelines,
but you can easily
switch XGBoost into them
without much effort.
So let me talk about our agenda
for the rest of the talk.
We're going to divide it
into three sections based
on the Google Cloud services
that are demonstrated.
And during these
three demonstrations,
we're going to refer back
to those stages of ML
that I just showed you.
So in the first case,
what we're going
to show you is how you
can use Google's building
blocks APIs to preprocess
unstructured data
so that you can use it in
XGBoost and Scikit-Learn.
And in the second
phase, we're going
to talk about Compute
Engine and how it can help
you do ad-hoc data
analysis at scale
very easily, and without
the pain and the difficulty
of distribution.
I like to refer to that
part of the talk as the part
where we make distributed
computing uncool again.
And then we're going
to finish by tackling
the topic of productionization,
in which we think about how
to integrate ML into your
production service in a highly
reliable way.
That's the part where
we're going to talk
about Google Cloud ML Engine.
So let's dive in.
So Google's machine
learning building blocks--
these are pre-trained models
that you can call into.
And they're accessible by API.
You basically can
use these models
to process unstructured data and
utilize Google's deep learning
expertise without having
to train your own model.
Building blocks exist for
natural language, speech,
translation, video, vision--
and more are coming
at this conference.
And increasingly, you can
customize these APIs endpoints
to your business's
needs with auto ML.
So they're becoming
significantly more powerful
and flexible.
I've talked a little bit about
structured and unstructured
data.
And I just want to quickly
define those concepts.
Structured data-- essentially
big tables of rows and columns
of strings and numbers--
is, in the grand
scheme of things,
relatively straightforward
to preprocess.
You can do it with expressions.
It's not that dissimilar
from spreadsheet operations.
And if you need to
do it at a scale
beyond what fits in memory, you
can use things like BigQuery,
or Spark, or Beam, or
Dataflow to do that.
But unstructured
data like images,
long paragraphs
of text, or video,
is more tricky to preprocess--
more tricky to handle in ML.
And it's really
where deep learning
and where neural networks shine.
And there's a lot of talks
here about those topics.
But an alternate
path, if you don't
want to write your
own neural network,
is to utilize Google's
building blocks APIs.
So just as an
example, if you have
a bunch of images
in your business,
you could train an
algorithm on them
by extracting the
objects within the images
and then use that as structured
data in a traditional ML
approach like
SK-Learn or XGBoost.
Or here's another
interesting use case.
It came to us from a
customer engineer in Japan
whose name is Hayato Yoshikawa.
I'm also going to
take this moment
to just say that in this
talk, I will occasionally
have to mention Japanese
and French names,
and I'm terrible
at pronunciation,
and I deeply apologize for
butchering these languages.
Hayato showed that
it's possible to use
Google's natural language
API to solve a tricky problem
with Japanese text.
So most NLP, most Natural
Language Processing,
starts with extracting
the words that
are in a sentence or
a paragraph of text.
And in English, this is easy.
You just split the
text on the spaces.
But in East Asian languages,
it can be more difficult,
because there aren't
spaces between the words.
So what Hayato
showed is that you
can pass the sentences
to Google's NL API
and extract the tokens out.
The results he saw
were much better
than you get from
Python libraries.
And with the tokenized
text in hand,
you can pass it to Google,
to Scikit-Learn's text
preprocessor, and
go on your way.
So let's see this in action.
I'm going to switch
over to my demo box.
It will take me a second.
Awesome.
OK.
So the demos today are
in Jupyter Notebooks.
And if you're not familiar
with Jupyter Notebooks,
I really suggest you
take a look at them.
They're a ton of fun to use.
They're like an advanced
version of a REPL,
a Read-Eval-Print-Loop,
where you can execute code,
mix and match it, and intermix
documentation with code.
So in this demo, what
we're going to do
is we're going to preprocess
headlines from "Hacker News."
It's an open data
set on BigQuery.
And we're going to try to figure
out whether the headline is
from "Tech Crunch" or
from "The New York Times"
by identifying the most
salient words in the headline.
Let me talk real quickly
about the dependencies here.
Basic stuff like
pandas and NumPy.
And then-- whoops.
Excuse me.
I'm on my second demo.
All right, basic stuff
like pandas and not numpy
as well as text preprocessors
from Scikit-Learn and two
Google client libraries.
So the first here reads
data from BigQuery.
And then the second
here communicates
with the natural language API.
So let's run this
line of code here.
And you know what?
I'm going to restart my
kernel so that I just
clear all the output.
I don't want to
spoil the surprise.
All right.
Let's start this again.
Perfect.
So we've imported
our dependencies.
And now we're going to query
the data from BigQuery.
This is something I really
love about Notebooks.
You can mix and match, actually,
different forms of code.
So in this Notebook,
for instance,
we're mixing Python code
with these BigQuery magics.
Magics are add-ons
you can install
onto Notebook environments
to do particular things.
In this case, the
BigQuery magic allows
us to write a query
here, and with just very,
very simple amount of code, read
it into a pandas data frame.
So here's that data
frame, or a preview of it.
The source here is
the target variable.
And the headline is
here, on the right.
So let's do a first attempt
to tokenize the Scikit-Learn.
And we'll see the problem.
So the problem here
that you see is
that the English
text is successfully
split into its
constituent words,
but the Japanese texts
left completely alone,
which is because
Scikit-Learn is just naively
splitting on the spaces.
So now, let's use Google's
natural language API.
We create a language
service client
from the Google client library.
And for each piece
of Japanese text,
we pass it to this
tokenize function.
What the tokenize
function does is
it calls the Analyze Syntax
method on that client,
takes the return value from
that and extract the tokens.
The tokens are joined
together with spaces
and inserted back into a new
column in the data frame called
tokenized text.
And now, if we run this
last cell in the Notebook,
we'll just show that
we've solved the problem.
We've run the exact
same set of code.
But this time, the Japanese
text is successfully
split into words.
It's a very simple example.
But I think what's
cool about it is it
hides a ton of complexity.
So here we go.
Oh, by the way, the
links to all the code
are going to be available in
the last slide of the deck.
So Google's high-level
machine learning APIs
can be useful in
preprocessing data.
But how about
infrastructure as a service?
Are we really going to
talk about virtual machines
in this talk about
machine learning?
And the answer is
a resounding yes.
So what kind of
scaling challenges
do users of Scikit-Learn and
XGBoost typically run into?
Well, scaling can
require more memory
if your data set is very large.
It can require more
CPU or GPU or TPU
if the best ML
algorithm for the task
is computationally intense.
And it can require more
processes or threads
if you have a big
hyperparameter space to explore.
And so when you need
to scale, you typically
think about
parallelizing your work.
So let me talk
about different ways
you can parallelize your work.
Hyperparameter tuning is
embarrassingly parallel--
embarrassingly parallel because
it's so easy to parallelize.
The only information that needs
to be shared from the workers
back up to the scheduler
is just the final results,
and then the schedule
just picks the best one.
Both SK-Learn and XGBoost allow
HP tuning to be parallelized.
Also, there are
ensemble methods of ML,
like random forests,
that can be parallelized.
And preprocessing
can be parallelized.
So you can switch
from pandas to Dask.
Dask implements the
pandas dataframe API,
but does so in a
parallelizable way.
And it's super cool.
And I think when many people
think about parallelization,
they immediately think
about distribution
across multiple nodes.
And I think that's
because our industry has
made a ton of amazing progress
in the last three years
through distributed computing.
However, often times,
you can actually
get a lot done
with a single node,
and it can be really easy to do.
Using large compute
instances to do your work
is becoming increasingly
more and more of a reality,
as costs come down and
the capacity of nodes
increases dramatically.
So here to tell you more
about this is David.
David Cournapeau
leads the ML team
at Cogent Labs, which is
a business in Japan that
specializes in applying deep
learning to B2B markets.
And as I mentioned, in 2007,
he created Scikit-Learn.
Thanks.
DAVID COURNAPEAU: Thank you.
Can you hear me?
[APPLAUSE]
It's good for the sound?
You can all hear me?
OK.
So thank you, Steve.
Thank you for having me.
I'm excited to be here.
It's the first time
at Google Next.
So as Steve mentioned, I've
been working for almost one year
now at Cogent Labs.
It's a startup in Japan, Tokyo,
where we do deep learning.
And so we try to apply deep
learning to programs that
were difficult to sort before.
So, for example,
we have a product
called Tegaki, which is Japanese
handwriting recognition using
deep learning.
We have a product called Kaidoku
for document understanding.
And we have also a system to
do time series prediction.
But today, actually,
I am not here
to talk about deep
learning, but I'm here
to talk about a lot of the work
that happened before, like when
you need to deal with data.
Because Steve already mentioned,
when you do a machine learning,
you need to actually
spend quite a bit
of time on the preprocessing.
So it's the unsexy part of data
science and machine learning.
Realistically speaking,
when you work on product,
that's most of what you
spend your time on, more than
on the models themselves.
And this part is actually
not that different
whether you're using
machine learning,
like traditional machine
learning like Scikit-Learn,
or whether you're using deep
learning through frameworks
like TensorFlow.
I want to talk a bit more
about that part, actually.
So the example I will use to
illustrate, a bit, my points,
is using one of the
project I've been
working on at Cogent Labs
for the financial time series
forecasting.
So we did this project
in coordination
with one of the biggest
brokerage company in Japan.
And we use, basically,
deep learning
to do time series prediction
for real time volume prediction
on the Tokyo Stock Exchange.
And the product has been live
since last month, actually.
But to do the deep learning
algorithm, you need data.
And it's a truism today--
the more data you
have, the better it is.
And so you have
this famous paper
from like 10 years
ago by Alon Halevy
and Peter Norvig about the
unreasonable effectiveness
of data.
So Peter Norvig is the head of
research at Google, actually.
Another thing he mentioned
early on when he was at Google
is, "At Google, we don't
have better algorithm,
but we have better data.
We have more data."
And like he said, some
things are really--
he used that already
intuitively before,
but some things that
really stayed with him when
he was at Google was how
even a simple algorithm
can work so well when
you have a lot of data.
So this whole argument about
the unreasonable effectiveness
of data and how
you can generally
improve your product,
not by changing the model
but just by using more data.
So with this whole thing with,
you know, it's almost a fad,
at that point, about large data,
big data, and the more data
you have and the better it is.
You have more and more data,
internet, blah, blah, blah.
What can you do?
Do you need to do
distribute computing?
Do you need to
always use Hadoop?
But I only have two engineers.
How I can do this, right?
So at that point, it's
almost a fad, but still
a real thing for some companies,
where you have large data
to use for your algorithm.
And the problem is, when you
have a lot of staff engineers,
they like using tools
for distribute computing,
because it's fun and
you have a lot to do.
So you have all these
great technologies
like Hadoop, Spark, Kafka, Beam.
Some of them will be mentioned
or have been mentioned already
in this conference.
And so as I said, engineers love
working with distribute data
system because it's fun.
But is large data really
eating the world, so to speak?
So this paper I really like.
It's a bit old now, but I
think the lessons are still
relevant today,
like "Nobody ever
got fired for using Hadoop."
And again, the numbers are a bit
old, because they're from 2012.
But I've noticed the same thing
in my previous job and even
currently.
So in this paper
in 2012, they look
at what was the median
size of a job in Hadoop?
Microsoft and Yahoo, the median
size was below 14 gigabytes.
At Facebook, 90% of the Hadoop
jobs they were using as a time
were for a job input size
of below 100 gigabyte.
And so there's this joke where
a lot of people like to say,
oh, I have a lot of data.
I have a gigabyte of data.
So I use Hadoop.
And so there's this famous
blogger and conference
speaker, Gary Bernhardt, where
he had this joke, like, I have
this new consulting
services where you bring me
your big data problem,
and I will tell you, well,
your data actually is
small enough to fit in RAM.
You pay me $10,000,
and then you don't
have to spend half a million
dollars on infrastructure.
And if it sounds
almost trivial--
you're like, I would never
make that mistake, right?
Of course if you have
a small data set,
I will not use Hadoop.
But that's something
I keep saying.
At the beginning of this
year, PyData, in London,
I was talking to this guy
working for a hedge fund.
And he said when
he joined, there
was this team of 15 people doing
a scalar distributed system
for a dataset that
was 40 gigabyte.
He fired all of them
and built a system
that was a bit better design.
So that's one big lesson
I want you to remember.
Maybe some people don't
make that mistake.
But when you have a
bit less experience,
it's easier to do this mistake.
But don't over-architect.
And the thing is, when
you do machine learning,
the typical data size for ad-hoc
analyses is often not that big.
Sure, you have
more and more data.
And of course, if you're Google,
you have a large data set.
Other companies have
a very large data set.
But most companies, they
don't have that big of a data.
And the thing that is
interesting, as well,
maybe you're storing
more and more data,
but the data you need to look at
when you look for a new problem
to solve, or maybe to improve
an existing algorithm,
you don't need to use
all the data at once.
Especially at the beginning,
when you do ad-hoc analyses,
you're not sure exactly
what you're looking for.
You want to understand
a bit better your data.
You can use a subset of this
data to do the analysis.
So the size of the
data for analysis
is not the same size as the
data you need for storing.
It's very easy to
underestimate the engineering
work you need to deal with
effective data architecture.
For people who've
used Hadoop, they
know you don't set up Hadoop in
one hour and then you're done
and you're using it.
You need people to take care
of it, like masternodes fails,
like some of your hardware
fail and you need to take--
that's a lot of work
to deal with it.
And especially when
you're a small company,
I think it's easy to
underestimate the loss of what
I call data agility.
That is the ability
to be able to not
scale the amount of data, to
scale the number of experiments
you can do with the data.
Like having data this small,
you can easily visualize it.
You can understand it.
It's really important for some
class of problems as well.
And again, most of the
work on machine learning
when you work on product
is not on the model itself,
but everything around.
So if you optimize
the part where
you need to have ad-hoc
analysis-- when you need
to do an ad-hoc analysis,
you should optimize that part
to be simple, where all your
data scientists can work
on a set up where they don't
have to fight the system
to get the data.
You can get,
actually, a lot back.
Because you can be faster
and you can develop new model
faster, understand
your data faster,
or plot the data faster.
So what was the link of this
observation with Google Cloud?
So again, data are
getting bigger.
I had mentioned before, don't
try to over-architect too much
your data architecture.
But something that
is interesting
when you think about
cloud services,
and GCP in particular, is,
you can get a really, really
large VM now.
Recently, GCP announced
that you can have VM
with four terabyte of memory.
That's a lot of data you can
keep in memory on one machine.
And when you look at the
trend of what is typical data
size that people
use in data science,
actually, you see it's
kind of plateauing.
So it's just one data sample,
but you have the "KD Nugget" is
a famous data science web site.
And every day--
every year, sorry--
they do a survey to ask
people, what is a typical data
size you're handing, et cetera?
And actually, you see that
for the last few years,
the median data size of the
data that people look at
is plateauing at a
few hundred gigabytes.
And five years ago, a few
hundred gigabytes, yeah,
maybe you had to use
Hadoop, or at least you
need to think a bit.
You're [INAUDIBLE].
But today, a few
hundred of gigabytes--
if I have to deal with this
today, I know what I will do.
If I can put the
data on the cloud,
I would just put
them on a large VM
where I can load
everything in RAM.
And then everything
becomes much easier for me,
and I don't have to over think
too much of the engineering
part.
It's not just about the RAM.
OK, you use a CPU.
It's kind of obvious.
But also, at least on GCP, you
have, also like fast local IU
available, right?
You can't create VMs
that have NVME SSD, where
you have more than one gigabyte
per second, like throughput,
when reading from disk.
So a lot of these
together means we
can have very powerful
machine where you can actually
get a lot done without going
too early to distribution.
The advantages are
fairly obvious.
If you're a scientist
who are maybe not
so strong on the software
engineering side,
they can focus on
their main expertise.
So they don't need to spend
time learning about Hadoop,
about Pig, Hive, whatever.
And they keep all the
interactivity of the tools
that people like to use in data
science, especially in Python,
and some of the tools that
Steve mentioned before.
So you keep the interactivity
on a single machine.
And you keep-- using Notebook
is easy, using [INAUDIBLE]..
All of that stays easy.
So concretely, if you look at--
I was mentioning before
this project we did
with investment bank in Japan.
So we have a fairly
typical problem.
We use deep learning
after, but it
doesn't matter so much for
what I'm talking about here.
So we use market data.
So we have tick data.
So tick data, for
people not familiar,
is just the price of each
stocks at each moment
it's coming from the market.
So concretely, we have between
1 and 200 gigabyte of CSV files.
It's already semi-aggregated.
We have 50 million
points per month.
So we had a bit
more than two years,
so we have a more than
one billion data points.
And some of the
analysis we had to do
was pretty easy to
parallelize if you want,
like some preprocessing.
It's each row independently,
so you could parallelize that
fairly easily.
Some things were a bit
less easy to parallelize,
like resampling.
You had this thing called
open bin detection.
It's boring, but basically,
it's kind of retrosave.
So it's more difficult
to parallelize.
And at the beginning
of the preprocessing
we had was quite
resource hungry.
You needed more
than 100 gigabyte
of RAM just to deal with
one of the CSV files we had.
So to make it a
bit more concrete,
I just show a bit
how it looks like.
So you don't need to really
understand the numbers.
But when you use market
data, the problem
is, each market data provider
has different conventions.
So you need to
convert between them.
You need to convert between
different market data provider
to a common format.
So boring, but again,
fairly typical things,
like removing some characters
in the symbol and all
of these kind of things.
And we needed to do that for
quite a few data points--
several billions.
And so we need to speed this up.
And so you may wonder, why
do you need to speed this up?
Preprocessing, you only
need to do it once.
You can save that
into a dataframe,
or maybe you can save that
to a parquet file, which
is a more modern
[? stylization ?] format that
can be styled quickly from-- and
to disk from pandas dataframe.
But the problem is,
at the beginning,
we were not sure exactly
which kind of preprocessing we
had to do, because again,
these market data are pretty
complicated, and
different banks actually
deal with them differently and
have different conventions.
So we had to go back and forth
with just the customer quite
a few times.
And so the speed of processing
was actually kind of important.
Because if it takes one
day versus one week,
it can make a
difference when you
need to talk to the
customer back and forth.
And so just by using
larger VM on Google Cloud--
nothing fancy-- pandas,
your bash scripting,
a bit of a [? parallel ?]
option to xargs--
you actually could
get quite a lot done.
And having the big VM allowed us
to iterate quickly, especially
in exploratory phases.
And I think big VMs
really allowed us also
to convert the CSV very
quickly to some other file
format that are more efficient
on the disk and the memory.
So really, the
takeaway here is there
was this fashion of
always scale horizontally,
because scaling
up doesn't scale.
Well, actually, for
a lot of things,
scaling up actually does scale.
Especially with the cloud
now, it's quite easy
to get really large VM.
And as long as you do
that for ad-hoc analysis,
I actually think it
works pretty well.
You can keep iteration quickly
for doing ad-hoc analysis.
I think VM actually are
getting bigger more quickly
than data are getting bigger.
At the same time,
you have two that
become more memory efficient.
So first of all, for
pandas, the rule of thumb
for Wes McKinney, the
creator of pandas,
is if you need to deal
with a data set of size
x, generally the rule of thumb
is you need 5x to 10x of RAM
to deal with this
comfortably into pandas.
But now, with tools like Arrow,
this factor becomes smaller.
So it's actually more
memory efficient.
So for a given amount of RAM,
you actually can get more done
and get larger data.
And some of those
lessons, they are not
specific to just preprocessing
or ad-hoc analysis,
but actually, you can apply
this in later phases, as well,
of your project.
So one of the way I like using
these kind of technologies
is for testing and
continuous integration.
Doing continuous integration
for machine learning models
is pretty difficult. How
do you write unique tests
for machine learning models?
How do you write--
you know, It's not as mature
as for standard software
engineering.
And sometimes one of the issues
is that it takes a lot of time
to just test even simple
things in your models,
especially when you
do deep learning.
Well, here, again, if you
can launch on demand, just
for half an hour, very large
VMs with a lot of cores,
you can actually get away
with simple solution,
and you don't need to, again,
over-architect too early.
All the lessons I'm giving
here, those are simple tricks,
and maybe it's trivial
for most of you.
But you can use them not
just for ad-hoc analysis,
but also for
testing, integration.
I will give back to Steve.
STEVE GREENBERG: Perfect.
Thanks so much.
You can take that.
Thanks, David.
[APPLAUSE]
Perfect.
So as you think about
scaling up your training
on single nodes
on Compute Engine,
I want to call your
attention to two resources
that I think can be really
helpful from Google.
So the first is called
Compute Engine burst training.
And there's a link there.
It will also be at
the end of the deck.
It's all on GitHub.
It's just a pattern
for doing your work.
And basically, it's
a set of scripts
that allow you to automatically
provision a machine,
kick off training, export
the results of training
to cloud storage, and
shut down the machine.
That's all done for you
so that you can basically
get your code correct
on a sample of your data
on your local machine,
and then, when
you want to train on
your full dataset,
you do that on the
cloud, but you do it
in a way that
minimizes your costs.
So you're able to just provision
that four terabyte machine
for just the period
that you need.
And the other became available
just about two weeks ago
on Cloud Launcher.
It's called the Deep
Learning VM Image.
And while it says
deep learning, I
think it's really helpful for
XGBoost and SK-Learn, as well.
It automatically
installs pandas and NumPy
and other common dependencies.
It automatically
starts up Jupyter,
previsions an SSH tunnel, and
gives you a little command
to basically browse to Jupyter
from your local machine.
Again, none of this
is rocket science,
but it can just make your
life a little bit easier.
So now, it's time for our
last section, Cloud ML Engine.
This is all about
productionization
and taking your code and moving
it into a production service--
which means that it's
highly available,
that you have a repeatable
process for deploying
and updating, and
that it responds
to real-time changes in demand.
And so if your service relies
on prediction for real customer
experiences or if you regularly
retrain your model on new data
as it comes in, Cloud ML
Engine can be a real help.
And at this conference,
we have announced
that Scikit-Learn
and XGBoost are both
supported for training
and prediction,
and both services are
generally available.
So first, let's talk
about prediction.
It's simple.
From XGBoost or Scikit-Learn,
just export the model
to a file, upload it
to Cloud ML Engine.
You'll have a REST
endpoint that you
can use to handle predictions.
Cloud ML Engine runs on
Google infrastructure,
so Google SREs are
holding the pager.
And as you'll see in this
demo I'm about to show you,
it can help you avoid
training-serving skew.
So training-serving
skew happens when
you process data differently
in training and in prediction.
And it can lead your
predictions to just not live up
to the expectations
set during training.
And the solution to avoid
training-serving skew,
or one aspect of avoiding
it, is to make sure
that you share
your preprocessing
code between training
and prediction.
And Cloud ML Engine, together
with Scikit-Learn pipelines,
can help you do exactly that.
So let's take a
look at it a demo.
So again, this demo is
in a Jupyter Notebook.
And this time, we're going to
predict the weight of babies.
Again, it's a data set
on BigQuery public data.
Predict the weight of babies
given basic information
that we might have available
when an expectant mother walks
into a clinic.
We know the age of the
mother and the father,
the gender of the baby, and
the length of the pregnancy.
In this demo, we've got a couple
of interesting dependencies
from Scikit-Learn that
I just want to show you.
The first is a
dictionary vectorizer.
This what we use
to one-hot encode.
So it's a really slick
piece of Scikit-Learn
that just takes categorical
data and automatically
one-hot encodes it.
Some of you may call that dummy
encoding, not one-hot encoding.
But it basically turns
categoricals into numbers
so that they're easily
understandable by an ML
algorithm.
We're training using
a random forest,
but it could be any model.
We're joining together
those two pieces together
in the Scikit-Learn pipeline.
We've got utility functions for
splitting our training and test
set, and joblib for
exporting the model.
We're going to use the discovery
API from the Google API client
to issue predictions-- basically
just build up a REST request.
And we are going to also use
BigQuery to read the data.
So let's run this.
Great.
Again, we load our
data from BigQuery.
And here's the data.
The weight here is
the leftmost column.
That's the target variable.
The rest of the columns
are the features
we're using to predict it.
So let's do some basic data
processing, separating out
our labels from our
features, making sure
that our categorical
data are of type string
so that the dictionary
vectorizer will correctly
handle them.
And then splitting our
training and test set
and constructing the pipeline.
At this point, we
have a pipeline ready,
but we actually haven't
done anything with it yet.
This next step-- again, this
is calling the .fit method--
fits the pipeline to the data.
And this output shows us that
the pipeline is correctly fit.
So what that did is, it actually
ran both steps in succession.
First, it ran the
dictionary vectorizer.
Then it trained the model.
And then on the local machine,
we can then call .predict
on the pipeline and
get our predictions.
Now, all of this has
been done locally,
which is all well
and good until you
want to run it as part
of a production service.
So now let's do that.
So we're going to use
joblib to dump out
the data to the
local file system
and then copy it up
to cloud storage.
So another cool
thing about Notebooks
here is that we're
mixing together
a magic that sets an
environment variable
with a call to the
shell, which calls
GSU to lend copies of the data.
So the data's up there now.
And now, let's create a model.
You can see I've practiced
this demo nine times.
All right, we're going
to create the model.
And the model is just
a container for us
to then put versions of the
model, which will actually
serve predictions.
So the meat of the
work is this command.
And I'm going to run it
and talk you through it.
It's a call to GCloud.
And we're creating a version
of the model asynchronously.
That just means the
Notebook returns
and continues
execution while waiting
for the model to finish.
We're passing it the model and
version name we just created.
We're specifying that the
framework is Scikit-Learn.
So the other two
framework options
are TensorFlow and XGBoost.
The runtime version of 1.8 is a
Cloud ML Engine runtime version
that specifies a
version of Scikit-Learn
and a version of
other dependencies
that are available to us.
We point to that file that we
just uploaded to cloud storage.
And we also specify that
at all points in time,
there should at least be
one node servicing traffic.
I may have mentioned
earlier, but one
of the cool things
about Cloud ML Engine
is it scales up
or scales to zero.
And if you have zero
nodes servicing traffic,
you pay nothing,
which is really nice.
But your business may
require you to always
have one node servicing
data, because there
is a small latency
cost of tens of seconds
if you're the first request
to provision a model.
If you want to avoid
that, you can do this.
Now let us see if
the model is ready.
It is not ready yet.
Let's give it one more
second, and then I'll
call the one before that.
All right.
It's ready.
So that shows you
about how long it
takes for the model to deploy.
And this last cell in the
Notebook is Python code.
It could be any
language you want.
This is just an HTTP
request to arrest endpoint.
We use the discovery API
to make it easy to build up
the request, and then we issue
it, passing the test instances,
in the payload.
And we print the predictions
out to the Notebook.
And if these numbers
look familiar--
6.44, [? 72.21, ?]
it's because those
are the same numbers
that we saw up here,
which is just an indication
that shows that we've basically
taken the same logic
that was running locally,
and we've moved it
up to the cloud.
But prediction is
usually only part
of a larger, end-to-end pipeline
that can involve retraining,
as well.
So here to tell you a little
bit about how that can work
is Laurent Candillier.
Laurent is a senior
data scientist at Ocado.
LAURENT CANDILLIER:
Thank you, Steve.
[APPLAUSE]
STEVE GREENBERG: You're welcome.
LAURENT CANDILLIER:
Thank you, Steve.
Let me start with
a quick context.
Ocado has been an online
retailer in the UK
since 15 years.
And it has known great success.
Thousands of order are placed
every day through our website
or application.
Then products are
picked up by hundreds
of robots in our huge,
automated warehouses,
and happy drivers
come to your homes
to deliver your goods
whenever you want.
And with time, Ocado
has also become
more than just a retailer.
It has become a tech
company robust enough
to sell its
technology to others,
from the website and the app
to the full system of delivery
using the full automated
warehouses and more
big data and AI.
Some of the biggest
retailers in the world
join our adventure,
like Morrisons in UK;
[INAUDIBLE],, in Spain; Casino
in France; Sobeys in Canada;
ICA in Sweden; and Kroger
here in United States.
So I have five minutes
to go to the point.
So let me jump to
an example where
the experience of Ocado
in big data and AI
can help other retailer.
Fraud detection is
a classical problem
that we face in online retail--
orders being delivered
and never paid for.
How can we face that?
With machine
learning, for example.
Features can be
derived from orders
and passed, along with the
non-class of failed payments
or not, to a machine
learning algorithm
that will learn a
model that will then
be able to predict if a new
incoming order will probably
be associated with
failed payment or not.
Type of frauds that
such ML models can learn
is if you pass more than three
orders in the future for more
than 500 pounds each and you
let us less than 24 hours
to do the delivery, well,
your orders are suspicious.
And remember one
important thing.
We are speaking
about big data here,
with all the retailers
in the world that
joined our adventure.
So the big question
here is how to embrace
the challenge of
quickly building
scalable machine learning
solutions ready for production.
As quickly as I
jumped to the problem,
let me jump to the solution.
It's called Google
Cloud Platform--
a great environment to run
machine learning on the clouds.
You can start with your data
lying in Google BigQuery,
and run some standard SQL
to join your data coming
from different resources, and
run some initial computation
of features.
You can then go
to Google Dataflow
to run some Apache Beam to
run some more complex data
processing like
data normalization,
for example, or data
transfer to other resources,
like Datastore, that can be used
as a first data access solution
to expose some of the
precomputed feature you will
need at serving time.
You can also use Google Cloud
Storage to store all your data
sets as files that will then be
read by Google Cloud ML Engine
to learn a model and expose
it as a REST endpoints
and thus be ready to serve
a prediction in real time.
And here is the important thing.
When we run the analysis of
comparing machine learning
algorithms to face
this problem, we've
found that XGBoost,
in many cases,
were the algorithm reaching the
best predictive performances.
But we chose to go to TensorFlow
neural network instead,
because it was embedded
in Google Cloud ML Engine,
and thus, we were allowed to
train and predict in the cloud.
And thus, we were
offering a solution
to quickly go to prediction
and to be scalable.
We would also have liked to use,
for example, decision trees,
for example, in
Scikit-Learn, to be
able to understand the
outputs of the models
and the prediction.
But again, we chose to go to
TensorFlow neural network.
And basically, with the
work of Steve's team,
this conscious decision
is not needed anymore.
We can take the best of all
machine learning algorithm
using XGBoost and
Scikit-Learn on the cloud,
deploy easily, train,
and predict on the cloud.
And so we can now have
better predictive performance
with XGBoost.
And the explanation
for fraud detection
can be important, because
it can be interesting,
if you provide the
information to a human,
to explain that you think
that this order is fraudulent
because of the basket
content or because
of the past behavior
of the customer
or because of the payment
method that is used.
But then if you want to really
take decision automatically,
for legal reasons,
you need to be
able to explain
your predictions.
So this explainability,
for us, is important.
So basically, big
data, machine learning
made easy on the cloud.
What's next, Steve?
STEVE GREENBERG: Great.
Thanks, Laurent.
[APPLAUSE]
Awesome.
I'm always happy to
take credit for things,
but I also want to just note
that I saw [? Marielle ?]
and [? Robbie ?] walk into
the room a few minutes ago.
And they're actually--
I did work on it, but
they were really the folks
who did most of the work.
So thank you.
So let's sum up by
dispelling a couple of myths.
I think you'll
sometimes hear that you
need neural networks in order to
do machine learning these days.
And I don't think that's true.
I think, hopefully,
we've shown you today
that Scikit-Learn
and XGBoost can
be really helpful in solving
a bunch of business problems
with ML.
And if you do have
unstructured data,
like images or audio files,
and you want to make sense out
of them, another option, instead
of building your own neural
network-- or certainly
something to consider--
is to process them through
our building blocks
APIs and then take the
structure out of that,
and then use XGBoost
or Scikit-Learn.
People may tell you that
you need to leave the Python
ecosystem to scale.
I also don't think this is true.
I think using some
of the techniques
that we showed you today, you
can scale up on single machines
and get a ton of
amazing work done
without having to go to
a distributed framework.
And people may tell you that
the only way to productionize
is to embrace containerization.
And certainly,
containerisation has its place,
and there is lots
of places where
it's very, very appropriate.
But I think for
many folks, the ease
of use of a managed service
like Cloud ML Engine
can be very compelling.
[MJSIC PLAYING]